这条视频很可能会被下架
但是我还是行讲
跟大家聊聊关于财富的人质吧
这个很重要
因为你的认识决定了你的行为决定了你的决策决定了你该干什么
但是他不是特别好理解
但是我想美国一段时间就给大家讲去扣造我的不太好理解的那种
但一定对于有意的那种
对吧咱不能光想收留这样子
带来的好处
咱有点熟的时候还得听一下
一五
首先我们能和大家分享认识这个东西是非常重要的
我为什么会讲这个东西因为很多人认为一讲认识就变成了冲动学了对吧
想象底还有人说这个事情
张云明说
人个人就在区别就是认识
为什么很久不太好理解
我给大家去想话一点认识什么简单来说三部三三件事第一件事情
你能看到什么
认识第一件事你能看到什么你的事也
第二认识你帮你做决策
就是你要做什么
能帮你做决策
这三的话认识怎么怎么做怎么行为怎么做
就是放画论行动
请云明去哪里吧
别老说我了说我了以后你没法了
以后我准备美国一段声给大家分享一些
细考一些人物我觉得你从他们身上学习
别没事老看帝国游就习近期情绪的
华其百万关注没啥用的
要到谁呢
和依吧
有人知道和依吗
有人真称并一串一起来
毕业按个闯试
别按大招吧
从另外一个联合闯试就照常朋友
承认很长一段时间是华人受负
这个和依呢
他
以前家庭条件
不太好运的父母是
就是后来父亲很长就确实了家庭条件不太好
所以他一直在为
是伤是决定一个人的未来所以花很多
花透明一样
学习学习特别客户
后来去的电台工作
后来一个偶然的事情他突然明白了
决定人命运的不是智商
那个东西是底线是下线
决定上线下什么是你的认知
什么事呢就是他有一个机会认识的造成朋友
他突然明白了起来是什么
所以后来成了必圈一件
对吧
那么
造的钱是什么呢
今天和他聊聊这个话题
咱们常话的说吧对吧比如说你去
你们学校想要不
我们周围的话你哪有指账
就是咱们说那个钱
其实就这个指上面硬的一些一些一些东西
然后你可以买
上线上外的东西
别人还相信
对不对
为什么呀
共识
信任背书谁做的信任背是背背书
国家做的信任背书所以在这个国家里给
打成了共识这种一些号使
对吧这就是钱
所以我们说什么是钱钱是信任的独良
是共识
一圈人的共识
大家领袖了对吧
其实这么说大家说很容易理解呀对不对
其实就回到送朝
你就更考虑一点点件事情啊
你明白他是怎么起源的
好
那么第二个事情 我觉得很多人就跑了一届了
但是你言的条件就跑了一届了 就是数字并
我能说吧 就有一种数字吧 好不好
数字 为什么它是之前的
公司
你看我们把那个叫法并 什么叫法并呢
就是国家跟你被数
在这个国家里面 大家都是 打成了公司 对吧
那么数字这个东西的话呢
它不是国家被数的
它也不是十五
但是呢 他有一堆人
全球有一堆人对他才成了公司 对这个数学的算法才成了公司
就那么多 透明了 对吧
大家就要一投入经历啊 算了 也订了一样
对吧
打成公司
所以这个东西是实现的 所以各位你看
一帮人信仰他
他是有公司的 这个东西他就是财富
大家能体会到这一样吗
只要一帮人都是共识的 都是信仰的
他就是财富 好了
我们说第三件事情
个人能不能发信吗
个人可不可以发信呢
我们讲两个 讲两个事吧
一个事是这样的 你这样的
你这样的 你啊
这位是的作者 就是保护国的用
有人知道他们就很早的时候 创业
好 来呢 对外经常发表一些
创业的文章啊 一些想法啊 对这个事的理解啊
这个时候是国操的一个人说啊
然后呢 很能有些人的
相信他的眼光
所以就很多人创业的时候就会找他
然后给他一些 但他给一些建议啊 然后投资啊
所以他就成就 后面特别有没有人的
外类类类类类类类
对吧 从那个外类类类类类类
除了了非常多的创业公司
他也常在这些公司的股东
对不对
那么他就有了很多的财富 是不是
那么各位
你们就知道吗 就是欧森萨E 的那個后来的创始人
这个人 你觉得吧
那我的二儿你天天在晚上
那个时候天天在晚上
分享一些他的智慧
他对世界理解他的世界观
对吧 他的判断 分享出来
然后越来越多的人开始相信的
相信他的眼光
相信他的信任呢 相信他的智慧呀 对不对
所以很多好的项目就会找他
就和哥哥的梦很像啊 对吧
好的项目找他
很多人就当他来投资啊 对吧
信任他
所以呢
他已经有了大量的财富
跟你看 财富是个什么东西呢
今天我们有
我是红金是细绝的
今天有东西是细绝的叫租利利
当更多的人把租利利集中在一起对的时候
那么多人信任的时候在一个小的圈子里面
你能不能发行什么东西呢
我给大家九里子啊 比如说
有一百人特别相信我
特别相信 我们只九里了
特别特别相信我
现在其中有一个人想从那个人身上
从他们拿活
但是展示手里
没钱
是不是 钱就开始不就怎么来的吗 对吧
然后呢
所以让我来做个背书
行 我在牵这个条
我给他 我给他背书
上面带上手印
那这一牵人是特别相信我了
他拿了我的这个条
去另外那个人呢
先把换得还过一段身的把钱给他
那我这个条好划势了
应该是划势的 对对
因为在这一千人里面
他形成了共识形成了新人的背书
是这个邏輯吧 对吧
钱最开始不就怎么来的
拿那个钱去对坏你
经营吗 是不是
大家都知道这个
这个森林奇迹是怎么来的 对吧
你就明白这个道理的 好
各位
所以我们就体会这样一点
如果有一对人群
有一些人群
他们特别相信你
特别信任你
而且打伤的公司
那其实你就用个财富
你有没有钱你都用个财富
所以各位 你怎么建立这种故事
如果你做的东西
总是可以别人提供价值
而且你总是给别人不断的建立信任
越来越多的人开始信任你
那他就是财富
所以各位
我不知道我有没有讲明买
钱到底是什么
从法庇到数次到个人注意力的
信任的公司
如果你能够理解这一点
好理解 如果你多理解这一点
你就知道
该怎么做的
所以什么是认知的
就是你的事业
你看到的什么
你的计则
你要做什么
然后你到底该怎么行为
你该怎么做